okay what's up guys my name is Jonah and
welcome to episode 9 of 3d game
development in jela now yeah so we're
going to move on to the 3d perspective
stuff
and just a quick disclaimer this is this
is quite complicated so I'm going to try
and teach you this as best I can but if
there is something that you do not
understand please leave a comment below
or send me an email my email address is
on the page of my channel and the
channel page and or send me a private
message through youtube okay if you
don't if you don't understand something
or tweet at me that's probably the best
way because yeah this stuff is going to
get really complicated yeah so let's
create a class which will basically
contain all of our all of our um our 3d
sort of perspective data so first thing
I want to do is I'm going to create a
new class and I'm going to call and I'm
going to make sure it's in graphics and
I'm going to call it render 3d and it
will I get was just created first it's
going to extend around a class okay and
we're gonna add that constructor and
stuff okay so my good friend not who
created Minecraft actually demonstrated
a really good technique for doing this
so um throughout this 3d sort of
creation we're going to be um want to be
using some of his code that he showed um
because I think I was actually going to
do it a different way and I'll show you
guys the way that I was going to do it
but um the way that he demonstrated is
really good because it ll it allows us
to change pretty much every every detail
every every little thing of how we want
our game to look which is really really
good so instead of doing it in like an
array he's basically just done at the
slow way which is which is good because
um
because it allows you to control the
game a lot more so yeah let's create an
object of this render 3d class private
private to private render 3d and we're
going to whoa is that I said to press
suppress something on my recorder than
how to get rid of that the heck was that
okay that was interesting
render 3d and render 3d and we'll call
it
we'll call it random let's call Crandall
and let's set render equal to we can
actually get rid of this draw we don't
want to draw anything last time we add
this so we're going to get rid of that
so to give us a black screen and we're
going to go ahead and type Brenda equals
new Brenda 3d was with the brown does
lip and height
okay awesome so let's go into render 3d
and start start doing this okay
so the first thing we want to do is I'm
going to make a public void actually not
private a public void I'm going to call
it render and this is basically actually
now I'm going to scroll floor and this
is based on a sort of render our floor
and ceiling as well but yeah and it's
basically gonna have a full loop so
again you know we I sort of explained
this earlier as well this is going to be
like a full loop for the Y as in Y
height we actually pretty much did the
same thing in our in our render class
but yet obviously we have a different
here and inside there we'll also create
a another for loop over for our beloved
X with what
and yeah and I want to make a few
doubles here um I want to I want to make
one called Y depth and I'm going to sort
of set that equal to Y minus height
divided by two and then what I want to
do is I wanna create another another
double and this is going to be I'm going
to call this one Z and 100 point zero
divided by Y depth okay Alex we'll see
how this works in a minute um also want
to make a okay first thing I want to do
is actually create another another
variable and I'm going to call it X
depth and this is going to sort of it
all makes sense once it's done and will
be X - width divided by 2 is pretty much
the same as you know as this and see
what else I'm gonna so I'm gonna like
multiply it by by our said value every
time that this loop completes so that's
what this means it's going it's going to
get multiplied keep calling it that
exdeath it's like it's going to get
multiplied by that every time this this
for loop runs and yeah and let's just
make another integer called X I've
called it X X because you know the name
ax has already been taken in obstacle
whatever you like and we'll have to cast
this to an end because X depth is a
double of course it's not an integer but
we want we want X to be an integer so I
we had a cost to it that's what this
called integer integer int in brackets
in front of whatever we want in rackets
and yeah that looks good oh and of
course we needed or actually render it
so again this is quite similar to
this is actually this is quite similar
to UM to this to this arm to this so
basically to this draw class except this
is a bit different now we're going to
set that equal to X yeah so we'll that
gives us and of course we need to
actually draw it so when I go ahead and
go render dot for render is the name of
our oh and actually we need to draw it
anyway draw render 0 0 ok so right the
flaw of course is the method and
actually we need to wait a draw test not
Randal so that gives us actually no hang
on okay
so that that kind of worked okay this is
really crazy um let's just see if we can
sort of okay
yes that's fine just running a quick
check don't worry about that okay so I'm
going to drink some water because I'll
some hard work there okay so you can see
sort of what we've created but econ it's
sort of divided into two categories into
two things let's actually try and
multiply this by yeah okay this is more
apparent so we sort of have like a
we sort of have okay you can sort of see
the floor on the roof here we sort of
have like a green thing and we can
actually emphasize that if we go ahead
and let's just shift this to five yeah
so you can really see the UM you can
really see the what we call the the blue
sort of part and I think if I shift this
left then yeah then you can really see
the green part so it's sort of like that
and we want to sort of sort of combine
the two so we'll hit we'll just put and
and yeah okay that worked okay so yeah
that's what it gave us um and I will
explain this in a minute but first thing
I want to do is sort of explain what I
did here because we've introduced a new
sort of operator here and this is
actually a bitwise operator
it's the and bitwise operator hence the
hence the sort of an thing and of course
it's different from this and also I use
the shift left and that looks really
good
and the shift right as well so and that
sort of showed us that and that showed
us this so yeah there's actually a whole
article on Wikipedia for bitwise
operation and you can sort of read up on
hand I'm not going to explain it this
tutorial just because it'll it takes a
long time to explain it's very
complicated it took me when I first
learned all these bitwise operators it
literally took me about a month to
actually grasp the concept of it bit
shifts are a lot easier I guess to learn
basically it's shifting the bits over so
this is this is a lot to do with with
binary that's why it's called bitwise
operation and ships in Java of course
are these and hands in and there's
arithmetic and logical and logical shift
logical shift in Java is three what
surfaces yeah right three writes there's
no three left's as well because it's the
same as as um as arithmetic shifts so
yeah that's sort of a quick little thing
so I'm not gonna explain it now but as I
said you know the link to this will be
in this in the in the description it's
basically just bit shifts bitwise
operation and you can find out a lot
more about it here but yeah so basically
gave us this image um and other other
than that I guess you know we we did the
standard thing we created an object at
around 3 3 D we called render we assign
it to something so that it wouldn't give
us that null pointer exception and we
you know with two parameters width and
height being the width and height of our
of our our frame and we came in here and
we created two for loops one for Y and
actually I think if I okay that's
yeah I'll have to animate that first to
show you guys but yeah actually once if
we could put that to 2.4 I think that'll
be bit lower maybe it's not gonna work
okay nevermind
um well okay
yeah so basically what this did is it
it's sort of well it gave us this image
but it also it rendered our our floor
basically it rendered all of this to the
screen and I don't think this is this is
this is not the sort of thing that you
can explain really easily basically it's
it's two for loops like we've created
for arm for this or is it it's basically
like two for loops that we created for
this for this draw thing so what it what
it's doing of course is is creating
pixels and we're using the array of
pixels except this time we're assigning
it to the value of X X and if we remove
this then once I'm going to give us
anything actually but we need to times
this by good number what's wrong with
this oh I forgot the x then it's gonna
you know it's going to give us something
and we can see the FPS counter as well
so 128 seems to work nice yeah and so
basically but this time we're assigning
pixels to X X and the value of X X being
X depth and the value of this is
actually let's just just rename this to
death that might be easily since we're
not using any other thing before um and
yeah except this time we're sort of
assigning it to to death and what what X
X is I'll sort of X second x value that
we've that we've created is is basically
converting this converting our depth to
an integer and using a bitwise operator
operator to um to sort to convert the
bits into something that's visible and
yeah so you basically I think that if
you sort of go through this and you sort
of look at it actually something that
might help is actually printing system
dot print line
depth I always look at the app that'll
that'll sort of that might help you I'm
not sure actually let's print xx okay
let's just stop this um yeah so you can
see that it's sort of printing every
value from negative zero point two zero
point zero from negative
what is it negative like 128 I think 115
to positive 115 and by by doing so you
know it's sort of it's creating it's
creating the screen for us and yeah
that's correct because we converted on
we converted our depth into an integer
which is that yeah I'm not sure why I
wasn't updating before but you can see
that it's sort of goes up to five and if
we change this taking a while to show up
if I change this to I don't know to
let's restart this you can see that it's
sort of only ranging from zero to two so
yeah so that's how that works and then
you'll go all the way up to ten now and
this is actually taking up a lot of FPS
I guess this rendering but yeah so
that's that's sort of that's sort of
basically the basis for 3d I don't know
it's really hard to explain if there's
anything specific that you don't get the
best way to learn this is just first of
all read it slowly I guess um and then
basically the only new concept that we
sort of grasped here is that and
operator and I think I'll actually
explain this in a bit more detail in the
next tutorial because I'm you know as
I'm recording something that that this
is obviously going to be important as is
this
this in the future so yeah yeah okay so
yeah so I hope you enjoyed this arm this
is this is something this is like a
really big step that's why it actually
didn't post it ate a tutorial yesterday
because I really wanted to to sort of to
do this one good and actually you know
what let's let's go ahead and call this
pre-alpha 0.02 because we we deserve it
we've gotten up to this and this is
where it's sort of going to get really
exciting so we're going to sort of
fine-tune this and what we're actually
going to do is we're going to we're
going to make a nice high resolution
texture and apply it to the floor and
the sand we might actually take that
that ceiling away in the future and sort
of we might yeah we might actually take
it up so that we have like an open thing
and we might even make like a sky
texture or something not with this but
with something else so next time we're
going to learn how to put textures onto
this and probably refine this a bit more
because um yeah but doing it this way
instead of using an array to basically
do all this for us is it's going to give
us a lot of control because as you can
see because it's going here and we can
basically just change all these values
just on the fly and we don't need it
when we don't need to do anything for
that so yeah so I hope you enjoyed it
and actually one more thing there's the
next the next episode is probably going
to come out in about two days because
this stuff is really complicated um
would you guys prefer from for me to to
sort of to apply textures and basically
get on with this and maybe then later
come back to explain this so basically
I'm giving you a choice here post
comment below um are basically the which
tells me to do either textures next or
explaining next okay
so post comment below and let me know
what you think okay that's it see you
guys later bye
[Music]
you